En este video vamos a hablar de las relaciones
entre variables dependientes e independientes.
Usaremos una máquina de funciones, una idea
ingeniosa para ayudarnos a comprender esto.
Nuestra máquina de funciones opera de una manera
muy simple: nos permite ingresar un número,
al que vamos a llamar Entrada, y a partir de éste
genera otro número, al que llamaremos Salida. El
número que sale de la máquina, la Salida, va a ser
el resultado de aplicar alguna regla o receta que
está determinada en el interior de la máquina.
Digamos que nuestra Entrada es un 6 y la regla
de la máquina de funciones es la siguiente: x 8,
quiere decir que cualquier entrada a la máquina
se multiplicará por el número 8. En este caso la
entrada es el número 6 y al multiplicarlo por 8,
aplicando la regla de la máquina, obtenemos
el número de salida que es igual a 48. Vamos a
ingresar otro número a esta máquina de funciones.
Digamos que esta vez la entrada será el 3, así al
aplicar la regla, 3 x 8, obtenemos una salida que
es igual a 24: 3 x 8 es 24. Hagamos otro ejemplo.
Ahora, nuestra entrada a la máquina es un 2, y la
regla de la máquina de funciones es por 5 menos 6,
así que multiplicamos 2 x 5 y luego restamos 6: 2
x 5 = 10 - 6 = 4, el número de salida es igual a
4. Ahora ya entendemos cómo funciona esta máquina,
y te propongo hacer algo distinto: intentemos
encontrar la regla de la máquina de funciones
a partir del número de entrada y conociendo el
número de salida, es decir, el resultado que
produce la regla de la máquina. Veamos este
ejemplo. En esta máquina de funciones entra el
número 5 y sale el número 8. ¿Cuál será la regla
de esta máquina de funciones para que al entrar
un 5 el resultado de salida sea igual a 8? ¿Qué
le tenemos que hacer al 5 para que se convierta
en 8? Voy a escribir estos números en una tabla.
Esta es la Entrada y esta es la Salida, y nuestro
número de entrada es 5 y el de salida es 8. Aquí
tenemos otra Entrada y otra Salida en esta máquina
de funciones: el número de entrada es 17 y el de
salida es 20. Ahora, ¿qué tenemos que hacer con el
17 para que el resultado sea igual a 20? Los voy a
escribir en la tabla. Otra entrada de esta máquina
de funciones es el número 30 y la salida es el
número 33. Una vez más, ¿qué tenemos que hacer
con el 30 para que el número de salida sea igual
a 33? También lo voy a escribir en la tabla. ¿Cuál
será la regla de esta máquina de funciones? Bueno,
parece que tenemos que sumar 3 a este 5 para que
el número de salida sea igual a 8, y si a 17 le
sumamos 3 el número de salida será igual a 20, lo
mismo pasa con el 30 y el 33, así que la regla de
esta máquina de funciones es + 3. Ahora hagamos
un ejercicio distinto, se trata de lo siguiente:
tenemos nuestra máquina de funciones, sabemos que
la regla de la máquina es x 2 + 2, y esta vez el
número de salida es un 6. En este ejercicio lo
que deseamos es encontrar el número que usamos
como entrada. ¿Cuál será el número de entrada de
nuestra máquina de funciones que al aplicarle la
regla de la máquina, es decir multiplicar por 2
y sumar 2, el resultado de salida sea igual a 6?
Voy a escribir este número de salida en una tabla.
Tenemos otro número de salida para este ejemplo,
y es el número 22. ¿Cuál será el número de entrada
de nuestra máquina de funciones que al aplicarle
la regla de la máquina, es decir multiplicar por
2 y sumar 2, el resultado de salida sea igual a
22? Para conocer la entrada en estos ejemplos,
podemos ir al revés en la regla de la máquina:
tenemos una salida de 6 y nuestra regla dice x
2 + 2, así que para conocer la entrada primero
tenemos que restar 2: 6 - 2 = 4, y luego dividir
entre 2, porque la regla dice por 2, así que para
conocer el número que multiplicamos por 2 tenemos
que dividir entre 2: 4 / 2 = 2, nuestro número
de entrada en este ejemplo es igual a 2; y por
último, en este otro ejemplo, la salida es igual
a 22: primero restamos 2, lo que nos da 20 y luego
dividimos 20 / 2 = 10, la entrada en este ejemplo
es igual a 10. Muy bien, después de revisar varios
ejemplos, ya sabemos cómo funciona esta idea de
la máquina de funciones. En matemáticas tenemos
nombres para la máquina, la Entrada y la Salida.
Llamamos Función a la máquina y a la Entrada le
llamamos Variable independiente, porque representa
una cantidad que se modifica sin condiciones, es
decir, podemos poner cualquier número para que
sea la entrada a la máquina de funciones, o para
que sea la variable independiente de la función,
y generalmente se representa con la letra X,
y a la Salida de la máquina de funciones la
llamamos Variable dependiente, porque su
valor depende de la entrada y de la regla
de la máquina de funciones, generalmente se
representa con la letra y. Y hemos terminado.